what's up gq i go by the name of
ludacris and today i'm going undercover
on the internet
it's actually me
we were filming i believe fast
seven right here or it might be six no
seven or maybe eight i just lose count
these days i don't know
let's check twitter miss camilla says
ask luda what artist has influenced you
the most you can pick from all
genres pop rock rap anything
that's a really good question and i say
some of the people that influenced me
the most
are outcast scarface even jay-z
b.i.g tupac just to name a few some of
my favorite artists
and i know that's all rap by the way
ludacris
serious question what do you think in
your opinion has been the smartest
investment you've made outside of music
i would say real estate i have a lot of
real estate all around the country and
um
it's all gone up in value so i would say
that's probably the smartest investment
i made
reply nick m equally as important a
question how does it feel to be a top
five
all-time rapper thank you very much for
that compliment
nick am i i mean it feels phenomenal man
it feels great
you know to be in movies uh one of the
top five franchises of all time and be
one of the top five rappers of all time
that's how i feel
yeah you may not believe it but it's
actually me
mr mcbabe says ludacris how did your
friendship with paul walker impact you
personally
what did he teach you about yourself and
life in general um it
impacted me more than words can explain
i can tell you he taught me a lot about
life about not taking life so serious
uh about giving back even more than i
already did
about the earth and about saving our
earth and our planet and our animals
it's a beautiful beautiful thing man and
it's great memories that i have with
them
now on decorah why does ludicrous go by
that name is it self-deprecating
joke what is the history behind the name
no it's just a fun name if you look up
the real ludicrous word in the
dictionary it just says
beyond wild crazy ridiculous i think
that pretty much
explains my videos my style everything
about me and that's why
i've named myself ludicrous and my first
name is chris
so it's just me being creative is it
true that ludicrous from fast and
furious movies is related to richard
pryor
that is a great question man richard
pryor is
literally like my fifth or sixth cousin
peoria illinois
we were out my mother is from illinois
he is on my mother's side of the family
so yes i am related to richard pryor
but it's kind of far down the line
tick-tock
that's not me doing that baby that's the
car doing that
three things how do you do that are
there any other cars like that will this
car be in the next fast and furious
movie
i can't promise that the new maybach uh
truck will be in the damn fast and
furious movie but
there are other trucks like that and how
do you do it there's a
there's a mode in there that makes you
do that like hydraulic bump
so when you get those new cars that's
what it does it does it on its own
you can kind of shake snow off you can
shake certain things off the car
it's pretty innovative and pretty dope
happy cinco de mayo everybody
somebody said how do i look so young if
you're over 21 years of age you got to
drink at least two alcoholic beverages a
day
and it'll reverse aging instagram
luda please tell me you're doing a back
for the second time album
now that i can't confirm or deny that
but that's a great idea i believe that
it's actually me why are you wearing the
arms from the get back video
i wish i was wearing the arms from the
get back video those are actually my
arms
i work out like six days a week i am not
able to keep up with the rock in the gym
but my lifelong goal
one day is to be able to do that more
quora what is ludicrous like in real
life
uh probably more down the earth and just
real chill
because whenever the camera's on i'm
always really really animated and
loud and crazy so i gotta balance that
out when i'm in real life with my family
i'm just real calm cool and collected
posted does ludicrous own a tesla i do
not own a tesla but
maybe one day i will we got to save our
planet and everybody has to do their
part
favorite car that i own at the moment my
93 acura legend that i still have man
this hat is over 250 000 miles on it to
this day
believe that instagram you really like
them accuracy yes man
i like acura's i like mercedes i like a
little bit of everything but
my mom has that accurate that's my mom's
fast and furious car as you see if you
go to my social media you guys can
follow me and you'll be able to check
out a lot more of fun like that
is ludacris getting the throwback the
one from fast too
yeah i don't know man it just started
growing and i didn't cut it who would
have known you check it out right now
this is all me baby
so yeah you never know i might just let
it keep growing
back to twitter all right my man savage
ludicrous any plans on a new ludicrous
album in 2022
the rap game needs luda i actually do
have plans to put out an album next year
glad you asked that i will be working on
it as soon as i get finished filming
this movie man that i'm filming right
now called end of the road with bo
bridges and queen latifah
next this is corey acj09w
question on the song war with god who
was you talking to cause you was going
in
i was talking to anybody who wanted to
smoke that's the best way to answer your
question
ludacris you just recreated your debut
album cover from 2000
you still got that chain bracelet and
watch from the original photo
man i probably didn't because what i
used to do was trade in
old chains in order to get money on the
new chain every album i had a different
chain so i don't even think i have
that same chain bracelet and the watch
from the original photos sorry to
disappoint you
it's me for real no seriously bryson
genre ludicrous i got a question
listening to southern fried intro the
guy who segues after your first verse
never noticed before but is that too
changed the answer to your question is
yes that is him talking on there
that's dope that you noticed wikipedia
in january 2020 ludacris acquired
gabanese citizenship along with his
mother and his three daughters
yes this is true my wife who is from
there grew up there
was born there actually actually
surprised the entire family
because she knew the government there
and they thought it would be an honor in
order to make that happen so she was the
one that helped facilitate that
so all praise is due to mrs bridges
youtube
anyone notice how all these people
helped justin rise as an artist
yeah man peaches remixed they sent it to
me they said they wanted to do something
they told me it was gonna be usher
myself and snoop dogg
and i got on there and i just did what i
did man what can i say
i had fun with it they put me on the
first verse i love the
finished product and it seems that the
rest of the world loves it too so i'm
glad you guys are enjoying the peaches
remix justin bieber
ludicrous usher snoop dogg all love all
right guys i'm sorry to go
but i got to get out of here that's it
until next time
peace out